[Música]
en los últimos siglos vivimos
innovaciones increíbles que se
materializaron en las tres grandes
revoluciones industriales aprovechamos
el poder del vapor el poder del agua
después descubrimos la electricidad y
todo eso cambió nuestro mundo para
siempre hoy estamos en el medio de una
revolución tecnológica
la cuarta revolución industrial está
cambiando la forma que vivimos que
trabajamos y que nos relacionamos
hace unos años tuve la suerte de estar
en singularity university la universidad
de google y la nasa para algunos el
disney nerd no sé por qué lo dicen
y en ese lugar tuve la suerte de conocer
personas de 50 países distintos haciendo
proyectos increíbles por ejemplo
construyendo robots construyendo robots
que levantan piedras después de
terremotos como el robot que está allí
el robot del medio está claro por las
dudas
o por ejemplo fabricando carne en
laboratorios y todos esos avances que
nos encantan en materia de biotecnología
inteligencia artificial robótica
todo eso existe solamente por el
crecimiento exponencial de los datos
ante los datos eran bastante difíciles
de conseguir eran caros de almacenar yo
me acuerdo trabajando en una empresa muy
grande que me decían vamos a dejar de
almacenar esta data para empezar a
guardar esta otra hoy eso ya no pasa más
porque cada vez es más barato almacenar
datos generando historia de casi todo lo
que querramos y eso mismo hace que
estemos duplicando la información que
generamos cada tres años y genera un
fenómeno conocido como el big data
piensen que el 90% de la información de
toda la historia de la humanidad se
generó en los últimos dos años
por lo tanto los datos están allí pero
no es suficiente hay que hacerles buenas
preguntas a los datos entonces para
gobiernos para empresas para
instituciones de todo tipo es vital
pensar para que quiero usar los datos
qué preguntas quiero responder cuáles
son mis objetivos cuáles son mis
problemas eso genera algo bastante
concreto y que puede poner a los datos a
trabajar para resolverlo los datos son
tan buenos como las preguntas que les
hacemos ahí donde aparece lo más
interesante de todo esto que es la
ciencia de datos la ciencia de datos
para análisis de datos avanzados o data
science es para algunos como
estadísticas nada más y para otros es
como la nueva electricidad eso que está
transformando todas las industrias que
conocemos
de alguna forma los científicos de datos
trabajan con todo tipo de datos grandes
volúmenes medianos pequeños volúmenes de
datos y con eso hacer diferentes cosas
qué datos usan datos de redes sociales
datos de los móviles de los teléfonos
gps las compras que hacemos todo esa
data se analiza y sirve para resolver
problemas complejos yo hace dos años
junto a dos amigos justo hoy cumplimos
dos años les mando saludos y también
estamos trabajando con estas tecnologías
todos los días que me parecen súper
cancheras
por un lado el científico datos tiene un
perfil bastante particular se supone que
los que trabajamos con estos somos
buenos resolviendo problemas con
estadística matemática lógica no sé de
qué se ríen
y por otro lado según la prestigiosísima
universidad de harvard
tenemos la profesión más sexy del siglo
yo no sé si es la profesión más sexy me
gusta mucho lo que hago pero dudaría si
es exactamente eso no si es interesante
pensar qué cosas puedo responder con los
datos el punto de la ciencia de datos es
cómo hago para encontrar valor en ese
enorme mar de datos que sirvan para
responder preguntas y para solucionar
problemas que permitan que las
organizaciones tomen mejores decisiones
por ejemplo las empresas nativas
digitales los gigantes que todos
conocemos como spotify google
mercadolibre tienen en el corazón en el
centro de sus proyectos los algoritmos
que son los que permiten hacer la
diferencia por ejemplo netflix toma el
análisis de toda su plataforma y genera
recomendaciones el 75% de los usuarios
de netflix mira las recomendaciones que
les hacen entonces una buena pregunta es
cómo hacen para hacer recomendaciones
tan precisas y que de alguna forma
reemplacen todo lo que se conocía
y esas recomendaciones las hace
analizando lo que hacemos y nuestro
comportamiento en la plataforma por
ejemplo si miramos desde un móvil si
miramos de una tele qué horarios qué
actores nos gustan más
todos esos datos se analizan y se
aplican técnicas de ciencia de datos
específicamente una que se llama machine
learning machine learning o aprendizaje
automático estudia la historia de lo que
hacemos y hace proyecciones a futuro
predice el futuro a partir de los datos
históricos eso es clave en todas las
empresas de hoy de hecho antes se decía
que las empresas que no incorporen
ciencia de datos iban a perder
competitividad hoy se dice que pueden
desaparecer si no lo hacen
y una cosa que siempre me llamó la
atención es pensar cómo hago para
aprender de esos grandes monstruos
digitales y traer buenas prácticas a
organizaciones más tradicionales creo
que es un desafío que todos queremos
asumir por ejemplo si hablamos de una
universidad la universidad podría
analizar mejor los datos de sus
estudiantes por ejemplo para evitar que
abandonen las carreras si nosotros
pudiéramos mirar las características que
identifican a los grupos que abandonaron
por ejemplo si llevan tardo en exámenes
se venden de una zona específica se
cursaba lenta el horario podríamos
intentar compararlos con otros grupos de
estudiantes y darle alertas es decir
este grupo tiene un alto riesgo de
abandonar y que los directivos tomen una
decisión basada en datos básicamente lo
que estamos hablando es hacer análisis
de patrones de comportamiento igual casa
netflix
de la misma forma podemos mejorar el
rendimiento de las organizaciones con
las técnicas de data science eso es un
simple ejemplo de cómo se podemos
aplicar ciencia de datos para resolver
problemas reales
lo interesante de esto si se fijan en
este gráfico es los perfiles distintos
que podemos tener
cuando hablamos de estas técnicas no
solamente tienen que saber de tecnología
sino que además de matemática y de
entender modelos de negocio diferentes
de saber comunicar esos hallazgos eso lo
convierte en un perfil súper específico
y muy buscado por todas las empresas les
quiero decir que hoy es una de las
profesiones con pleno empleo en todo el
mundo
y más piense en las posibilidades que
hay que estamos analizando menos del 20
por ciento de la información no existen
cuantas posibles más tendremos en estas
industrias yo creo que si hablamos de el
pasado fíjense lo viejo que soy que
cuando empecé a buscar trabajo me
acuerdo que trabajan los diarios ha
buscado los avisos y uno de los
requerimientos que pedían para los
puestos era saber navegar en internet o
sea había que estudiar para navegar en
internet
hoy parece una obviedad todos sabemos
hacerlo de la misma forma en los
próximos años todos vamos a tener que
saber analizar datos por lo menos de una
forma básica
por eso las universidades se están
empezando a ver eso están creando nuevas
carreras hoy en un montón de cursos hay
maestrías hay diplomaturas nosotros
podemos hacer si queremos trabajar de
esto carreras técnicas como ingeniería
en software en informática estadística
matemática o algo menos técnico por
ejemplo como marketing o administración
de empresas y después de hacer un curso
de posgrado para especializarnos en esto
eso nos está demostrando todo el futuro
que se viene respecto a esto y creo que
algo que me interesa muchísimo es la
diversidad de los perfiles que están acá
adentro no es un perfil netamente
técnico a mí en particular me encanta
porque yo soy ingeniero pero también
estudié periodismo entonces en muchos
trabajos que hice era mirado medio de
raro por el costado porque tenían
intereses bastante diferentes hoy eso no
solamente es algo aceptado sino que
también es deseable que los proyectos de
ciencia de datos haya esa diversidad de
visiones
y pensando un poco en el futuro de todo
esto les quiero decir que para 2025 se
espera que estemos generando 163
zettabytes 163 zettabytes es el
equivalente a ver el catálogo de netflix
500 millones de veces ya deberían estar
haciendo pochoclo cada cual para llegar
eso es una de las cosas que se esperan y
además va a haber ciertos factores que
incidan en el enorme crecimiento de los
datos que vamos a vivir fíjense por
ejemplo nos escucharon hablar de
internet de las cosas o de los objetos
conectados cada vez vamos a tener más
cosas conectadas a internet desde una
cafetera hasta un auto
todo eso generando datos vamos a tener
teléfonos móviles conectados a internet
con 5g navegando muchísimo más rápido
que hoy y también va a haber un
crecimiento de este tipo de computación
la computación cuántica que de alguna
forma va a ir reemplazando a la
computación tradicional que tenemos
hasta hoy eso va a hacer que el big data
quede chico y va a venir una nueva era
la era de george data o de datos enormes
estos datos enormes nos van a preocupar
más de cómo obtengo los datos se van a
preocupar directamente de cómo hacer
para mejorar productos mejorar servicios
y mejorar experiencias y van a ser el
principal activo de todas las
organizaciones que quieran transformarse
digitalmente
pero les quiero decir que no tengan
miedo porque las profesiones
tradicionales no van a desaparecer con
todo esto sino que se van a tener que
empezar a complementar mucho más con la
tecnología
y principalmente pensando en que la data
se convertirá en la madre de todas las
mega tendencias que están sucediendo la
data como centro de todas las
transformaciones digitales y cuando les
digo de cómo nos podemos complementar
les sugiero este enfoque por ejemplo
podríamos dejar de ver un poco más a la
tecnología como terminator no como el
destructor de la humanidad y empezar a
verlo un poco más así como jarvis de
ironman que lo ayuda a cumplir con sus
misiones después por estar no le hace
caso pero no importa la información se
la da son las dos visiones que podemos
tener yo creo que la segunda de un
complemento es mucho más rica y además
por otro lado yo creo que el
comportamiento humano y el conocimiento
humano la empatía la creatividad la
capacidad de resolver situaciones
inesperadas nunca va a dejar de ser
necesario
y si todavía no los puede convencer de
que se meten en este mundo de los datos
les quiero recordar tres cosas la
ciencia de datos es una de las
profesiones más buscadas del mundo
se duplica la cantidad de datos que
generamos cada tres años y lo más
importante de todo es la profesión más
sexy del siglo 21 muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]